gosto de coisa impressionante entendeu
eu sigo ou assisto ou procuro busco
coisa assim impressionante Tipo se é
alguma coisa de box por exemplo é alguma
coisa muito massa não é só Tipo dois
caras lutando box é alguma coisa muito
impressionante uma parada que foi muito
você porque eu olho assim e vejo assim
nossa esse cara tem um o cérebro dele é
diferente dos outros lutador porque esse
negócio é muito sabe tipo eu vejo um
lance ali p e parece rápido não dá para
ver nada aí quando bota em câmera lenta
Dá para ver que ele saiu de um soco saiu
de outro saiu de outro fez assim Fez
assim Fez assim nada pegou nele ele você
vê que tipo por foi muito rápido então a
cabeça dele é muito rápida aí eu acho
legal a cabeça dele ser muito rápida e
curto e gosto disso assim ou o cara vem
de bicicleta aqueles negócio da Red Bull
o cara vem de bicicleta dá um mortal
puxa o paraqueda eu acho louco Tipo quem
quem quem olha assim e fala sei consigo
e bota e vai porque eu não vou não